I am 26 years old as of today which I
think means that I'm now officially old
enough to just start espousing wisdom
just here there and everywhere so that's
what I'm going to do here is a list of
26 things I have learnt in 26 years of
being alive just because someone beats
you in an argument doesn't mean that
they are right just means that they are
better at arguing than you which is a
very different thing always check that
you've turned on the microphone before
you start recording try to learn to be
comfortable with being uncomfortable
it's so much easier than trying to
resist discomfort that never works at
least for me your opinions are not who
you are they are just like things you
carry around with you in a box and you
should always be willing to change them
out for anything that might be better
not everyone can be a great chef but a
great chef can come from anywhere I
promise that that quote applies to more
than just cooking and cooking rats not
cooking rats but like rats who cook just
what faretta don't rely on talent talent
is like 1% of success and 99% of success
is really really hard work as far as
your brain is concerned there is no such
thing as multitasking every time you
switch between a task your brain uses up
energy so stick to doing one thing at a
time just because something is popular
doesn't make it good but doesn't make it
bad either it's not just teenagers who
get spots like every you just keep
getting them dirty never ends it never
ends just because something might seem
like an incredible coincidence doesn't
make it magical unlikely things happen
literally all the time that thing that
you don't like about yourself
it isn't a part of who you are most
likely it's just a habit that you've
developed and habits can be changed
parties aren't actually that bad it
turns out if you go to a party with
people you actually like they're pretty
good that one seems obvious I know but
it took me way too long to learn it
although our culture makes asking for
help seem like the weak thing to do it's
actually the strong thing to do and it's
the right thing to do as well if you're
making mistakes don't worry about it in
fact congratulations you're making
mistakes that means you're actually
trying something for every piece of
advice
that you get you should consider the
opposite side of that advice because
that might be more appropriate for you
personally or to put it another way if
any advice I've given to you today
doesn't work for you not my fault if you
are ever in doubt about whether or not
it is just a fart hold it in just in
case you never know people you never
know if you drink too much soda start
drinking sparkling water instead it's
more refreshing and it tastes similar
enough that it should replace it at
least that's what happened for me and
don't let anyone knock sparkling water
events blooming brilliant if somebody on
the news says that you were on Oprah
even if you deny it immediately people
will still think you went on Oprah ten
years later that one doesn't apply to
everyone but still follows me around
everybody dies so maybe don't worry so
much if there was a typo in your last
tweets or a typo in someone else's tweet
for that matter
if you want people to listen to you
don't try shouting try being quiet and
speaking softly and then people will
actually have to try and hear what you
have to say in real life the average
person doesn't actually exist so never
try making something for the average try
making something for everyone if you're
going on a school trip and you're
worried about wetting the bed bring a
bottle of water with you and if you do
wet yourself just pour the water on and
be like oh I spilled some water on
myself it didn't work for me but it
might work for you there are two types
of fear the fear of danger and the fear
of doing something very important and
you have to learn the difference between
the two just because it might be easier
to ask for forgiveness rather than
permission
doesn't mean you shouldn't ask for
permission don't do something because
it's easier do something because it's
the right thing to do Oh Apple Cinnamon
Cheerios are undoubtedly the best type
of Cheerios that that's all there is to
that one just because somebody tells you
what their problems are doesn't mean
they want you to try and solve them
sometimes people just want someone to
listen to them and that I think is 26
things unless I counted wrong before I
go just a little bit of housekeeping I
wrote a book
now it is coming out on the 20th of
October here in the UK and I think the
18th in North America so you get it a
little bit early speaking of the book
I'm also going on tour currently I'm
planning on going to five different
cities in the UK definitely I'm also
doing an event in New York City the UK
signings I have planned are ticketed but
you pay you for a copy of the book which
I will then write in for you and if you
want a signed copy of the book but you
don't want to have to see me in person
you know you don't want to have to smell
me or something then on the Waterstones
website they're selling signed copies
for exactly the same price as a regular
copy of the book almost as if my
signature is worth nothing but it might
be worth something to you so if you'd
like a copy you can go there all of the
links will be down in the description so
yeah please do come along it'd be lovely
to see you
and of losing light now so I should
probably go goodbye you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool thank you very much for
watching do check out my last video if
you like it is pretty heavy though it's
about anxiety and depression so only
watch it if you're feeling up to it and
if you're not I'll also give you a link
to a different video that I've liked
recently nothing to do with me just I'm
a fan of it and I'll see you very soon
I've got some things planned baby so be
prepared and that's all okay bye bye
also yes I have learnt more than 26
things in 26 years you don't need to
leave that comment thank you very much